is investigative reporter and foxnews
contributors we have Sarah Carter also
Gregg Jarrett Fox News legal analyst
Congressman Matt Gaetz all right let's
talk about your well you got a quote
today in your article hello everybody
this is amazing oh yeah
first of all members of the FBI like
we've said before Sean these are good
people these are people who want the
truth out and former senior FBI
officials as well as current FBI
officials do not believe that this was
just a technical glitch I can't even use
the language that they shared with me
when they heard the news come out
something that they did bring up that I
think is really important to get out to
the audience's they said that a lot of
these text messages were done on these
unsecure Samsung five you know yeah the
glitch so it wasn't just about capturing
it in US servers but they said foreign
actors such as Israel even Germany
Russia China and others try to capture
FBI cell phones all the time so it may
be that a foreign actor actually has the
text messages between oh yeah Tamir
might have it at all
somebody else may have it after all and
they talked about Flynn being the
subject of blackmail what about them
being the subject of black I have people
I don't want to mention their names they
didn't give me permission but they're
telling me Samsung phones don't have
point-to-point encryption or iMessage
and that those text messages are
retrievable through the carrier now they
may have been gone but some point but
certainly they would have a time and
date stamp wouldn't they if the they
would if the evidence was actually
destroyed it may have been obtained
first before it was destroyed by the
inspector general Michael Horowitz and
there's some indication at Henry's
reporting this that that is the case if
so we will invariably get to the bottom
of destruction of evidence and
obstruction of justice Matt Gaetz
congressman we've got our 18 and a half
minutes of missing tape here if you will
but this is far worse than Watergate
explain why you believe so because you
went over to see the memo that we
deserve to see well absolutely Sean and
thank you so much for the leader
you've provided and encouraging the
American people to demand the release of
this memo it is no longer disputable
that a pro Hillary Clinton anti-donald
trump bias has intractably infected the
FBI and the United States of America is
in jeopardy as a consequence in Sean you
laid out a great timeline but there are
even more damaging facts to come I know
that's hard to believe but trust me
around the corner we're going to be
learning even more about how infected
this investigation is particularly the
Muller probe just look at this in August
you had struck and Paige saying they
were going to be the insurance policy
they were gonna save America from a
Trump presence and how you gotta get it
bring us into your world here how well
Shana I can say this wait till you
overlay this five months of dark period
with the memo that we want to release it
well these are not isolated incidents
that are separated from one another you
have to evaluate these things you
believe they're missing because I don't
buy it
after Lois Lerner after Hillary Clinton
bleach bit acid wash with difference
Isis I don't buy it
I don't debbie Wasserman Schultz smashed
hard drive this is bull this is the
American people are never gonna believe
that two days after Barack Obama sick -
the intelligence community on President
Trump that all of a sudden these text
messages went dark and then they just
happen to reappear and come alive the
day after Robert Muller is selected to
be the special counsel it would be the
coincidence of all coincidence right
Sarah each tie this together with what
congressman gates is just saying you see
a connection oh absolutely congressman
gates brings up several really important
points and according to the people that
I've spoken with you know the this went
back to 2015 these text messages were
supposed to be stored and they should be
stored the fact that those five months
the most important five months of the
investigation are missing is highly
concerning and FBI agents law
enforcement US intelligence officials
say they believe that these text
messages will be retrieved and Greg you
made a very good point
if Horowitz did get those text messages
without them knowing and they withdrew
they went in and somehow tried to clean
it up
look they would have to go to their
records management system at the FBI
they would have to have somebody in
there help them clean this up let's talk
about the legal aspects of what we're
looking at here and what does the
Loretta Lynch component say to you it
says to me the fix was in as you
described it in your monologue which is
obstruction of justice and if a false
document was used to not only launch the
Trump Russian investigation but to spy
on Trump associates that's a violation
of the law it's abuse of power is called
deprivation of rights under color of law
22 USC 242 18 USC and people should go
to jail the penalty is 10 years behind
bars and it increasingly looks like this
was a widespread nefarious and illegal
plot to frame Donald Trump and clear
Hillary Clinton all right thank you all
for your hard work
you two deserve Pulitzer's and and John
congressman we need you guys to fight
and release this we release the memo and
find the text that is our you know hash
tag tonight